[Música]
a
este lunes inicia un nuevo
capítulo en la larga batalla contra la
extradición del fundador de wikileaks
julian assange quien enfrenta 17 cargos
bajo la ley de espionaje de eeuu que de
ser extraditado y ser encontrado
culpable podría enfrentar una pena de
hasta 175 años de prisión al inicio de
esta audiencia el abogado defensor de
assange yo aseguró que hacía seis meses
que no había visto a su cliente y por
eso el juicio inició con unos minutos de
retraso además desde temprana hora se
han dado cita en esta corte penal
bailey en el centro de londres un grupo
de simpatizantes que están pidiendo
liberar assange y evitar su extradición
a eeuu
[Música]
en australia país natal de julian
assange organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos y de la libertad de
prensa además de varios líderes
políticos le han pedido al gobierno
federal que intervenga para frenar su
posible extradición hacia eeuu y que
además lo traiga de regreso a australia
para garantizar su seguridad personal
pues temen que de ser extraditado el
fundador de wikileaks pueda sufrir
tratos crueles e inhumanos en prisión
sin embargo el gobierno federal de
australia encabeza el primer ministro
scott morrison ha decidido tomar
distancia del proceso y no intervenir
del todo aquí en australia assange
cuenta con más apoyo de la ciudadanía y
de organizaciones independientes que el
propio poder político que podría
ayudarlo
[Música]
en ecuador la decencia julian assage
aseguró que el país andino quedó
evidenciada como transgresor de los
derechos humanos de un ciudadano
ecuatoriano según afirmaciones de su
abogado carlos poveda su condición de
ecuatoriano se mantiene vigente y no
existe la suspensión de la
naturalización tal y como lo señaló el
ex canciller josé valencia sus abogados
aseguran que las condiciones y entrega
el levantamiento del asilo nunca fueron
verificadas según manifestó su equipo
legal a propósito del inicio de la
segunda fase del juicio sobre la
solicitud de extradición cursada por los
eeuu over aseguró que el gobierno
ecuatoriano nunca avaló los criterios
reales en su intriga y resaltó las
demandas frecuentes contra el estado
ecuatoriano ante las cortes
internacionales en ecuador también
quedan pendiente las denuncias
presentadas en contra de tres
diplomáticos de la embajada de ecuador
en londres ante la fiscalía ecuatoriana
por espionaje y 20 de información
reservada a miles de comunicación
españoles investigaciones que en el caso
ecuatoriano nunca recibieron en
respuesta según su defensa pero pudiera
tener afirmó que se realizó un reemplazo
el pedido de extradición que a su juicio
es aprovechado por los eeuu para
presentar nuevas pruebas desconocidas
que atentan contra el derecho de defensa
de julian
[Música]